[Music]
me
[Music]
in 2017 polish game development studio
draw distance release serial cleaner
with a string of successes to its name
the story continues
today we will learn what 2021 has in
store for the acclaimed franchise
so what was exactly the niche that
serial cleaner filled
draw distance didn't just come into a
vacuum and invent crime drama
instead they have replaced killing with
cleaning
do you think cleaning is boring yeah i
hear you but how about sliding on blood
and then using a vacuum to clean it
ever heard about mr wolf from pulp
fiction we will solve some problems as
well
we replaced the cartoony slapstick with
cynical 90s humor
then moved into new york city and went
bigger on everything else for the
development team
one thing was certain the sequel had to
be ambitious
better graphics in true 90s fashion
we're moving to 3d
refined gameplay more playable
characters wholesome soundtrack
and a believable ai
we don't want you figuring out our
meticulously crafted puzzles
we are much more into giving you some
funny tools so you can solve problems
the way you want it
if you are into sneaking that's cool
we've got you covered
but if you're not give us a chance no
matter which character you play
there's always some room to express your
more unconventional playstyle
what would be a concept without the hero
this time around
there's an entire ensemble
[Music]
while bob the anti-hero of the prequel
makes it comeback
we introduce three new playable
characters in serial cleaners
each character is tied to a map and has
a unique set of abilities
erin reed aka viper is a skilled hacker
and the youngest cleaner on the crew
even though she's secretive about her
past
her wit and her skills landed her a job
she would never
think to enjoy this much every hero
needs a scene to truly shine
let's have a closer look on one of the
levels
rather than constructing each asset
separately we
created our levels painting it all at
once
treating it as a huge artistic canvas
layering
multiple paint stroke graffiti tags
visual effects
and then purposely damaging it the same
way that basket did in his work
in order to truly appreciate art a
context is required
the main inspiration here is jean-michel
vasquez
who was the head of his time and inspire
future artists attention to detail is a
virtue that is cherished at draw
distance
we draw inspiration from 90s pop culture
sure
but to tap into its unique atmosphere
you have to live
and breathe the 90s i drive a 90s suv
i play games on cds and cartridges binge
movies on vhs tapes
i even switched to ms-dos laptop we're
going full method on this one
psycho is one of our more eccentric
cleaners he carries a chainsaw under his
coat which tells a lot about him
he chops bodies and neutralize people by
throwing glimpse at them
guess what kind of music he's into
every era has its own sound and the
sound of the 90s was truly profound
hey i'm josh eustis i'm writing the
music for serial cleaners i've been
known
for recording under the name telephone
tel aviv for about
22 years now but i've also played in
9-inch nails and produced other bands
the composition job on this video game
is really difficult what we're doing is
creating a sort of ecosystem of music
that we're all related in the way that
these musics were related in the real
world most of the music is sort of
rooted in
kind of 90s subcultures east coast
hip-hop stuff
body music that was popular in the 90s
kind of early rave
related music and then there's a one guy
bob who
tends to like sort of late period ecm
jazz which
is more of a 70s 80s thing because he's
a little older
kind of an imaginary 90s for a sort of
alternate reality i guess
every story comes to an end but good
stories get a sequel
with a capital s
you